luke tom nate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're here on
another camping adventure but
this time we're going caving
down in this hole
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
what do you think should we go camping
here let's go gather up some firewood
guys get some sticks and stuff
and you see those logs yeah i got logs
this is gonna be a different
sort of camp out first off we're camping
in an actual official campsite which we
don't do too much
but also we're going caving like real
down
deep in the earth caving and it's gonna
be
pretty crazy um so we're gonna have a
good time
and i've got some awesome food to cook
up as always and i'm gonna try a new
recipe today so
hopefully we're gonna have a whole bunch
of fun things to show you guys
going to go and cut open that bag and
pull the firewood out and stack it up
nathan here's the tent i'm gonna put you
in charge of setting it up okay
one nice thing about being in a campsite
like this is that virginia has really
strict open
burn laws so you can't have a campfire
in a lot of situations in the wintertime
but this is a federal park and federal
land so state laws don't apply
and under federal law we're allowed to
have a campfire so that's one nice thing
about
being here in a park all right for
dinner tonight we're gonna try to make
pizzas so i've got one part bread flour
to one part all-purpose flour here
we're gonna add some water and yeast to
it and see if we can't get something
interesting
but i forgot to bring sugar so uh
i'm not sure how this is gonna go but
we'll give it a try
because i forgot sugar i'm gonna try to
just add more yeast
okay like go ahead and see that little
ring
here here clip okay why don't you guys
go
pull out your sleeping bags and inflate
your mats this will be good practice
all right let the yeast in the water sit
for a little bit now we're gonna knead
up the dough
that's amore now we got a nice ball of
dough we need to give the yeast about an
hour to do its thing
but it's really cold out here and i
don't have any sugar so we need to warm
this up i'm going to put it in the car
and hopefully
we'll get some rising it's kind of sunny
today so maybe if i put it on the
dashboard it'll warm up a little bit
yeah it's nicer in here well nathan tom
you guys want to start the fire right
now do you want to use matches flint and
steel
blast match or blow torch
blow torch make a pile of little sticks
in the fire okay
all right rock paper scissors shoot
so i waited till aunt melissa was asleep
and i go
oh
let's check out the bread dough oh
yeah it's grown a little bit no
no should i start throwing the pizza up
in the air oh yeah
i could do it i've thrown a few pizza
pies do you have made a pizza before
yes my little boy
i couldn't see it i didn't see it this
has the word pizza in it
pepperonis are spicy oh i never knew you
could
like act more yeah oh yeah now i'm going
to show you our secret for baking over a
campfire
i've got two of these shallow baking
trays and i'm going to sandwich them
together with some c-clamps
okay oh look at this we've got good
coals here okay let's hold the hand over
one two whew
that's hot
okay
so cooking over open fire is always a
little bit sketchy so
use your nose to smell if the food's
burning and
use your ears you can hear when the
cheese is bubbling
okay let's see
whoa what do you think of that that
looks boiled
that looks perfect who wants a huge
piece
i don't have a piece
all right let's check the bottom oh
that's not bad
it's really hot buddy does that smell
good
that is a gorgeous campfire pizza
look at that i managed a pretty good
crust despite forgetting the sugar
okay that's a good crust i'm proud of
that we're in the south here so we're
going to have
some proper southern dessert we're going
to have some buttermilk pie
who wants some pie try that see what
today
[Music]
[Music]
it's like a nice smooth custard like
your arteries are embraced in a
warm hug from a southern grandma for
second dessert we have
quite a treat we have sour apple
marshmallows strawberry marshmallows
that are shaped like strawberries
peach marshmallows and the best
we have chocolate marshmallows with
chunks of chocolate inside them
all right get your marshmallow sticks
you want sour apple i know you oh the
sour apple smells like a jolly rancher
and it's already done
[Applause]
you need help
[Laughter]
is that awesome awesome
it's too crispy nathan's got like a
shish kebab here he's got a strawberry
an apple you should put a chocolate on
there too
all right we're gonna try a chocolate
one is that a chocolate one
oh boy that looks so crispy on the
outside yeah
i've never cared that much for roasting
marshmallows that chocolate one was good
who wants some hot chocolate i do okay
let's get you some hot cocoa
hold that hey top you like your hot
chocolate yeah
good you guys want to go get in the tent
warm up and uh watch some shows on the
phone
yeah all right let's do it i got my mr
heater little buddy heater
i got it hooked up to a 20 pound bottle
here
these little mr heater little buddy
heaters are meant for ice fishing shacks
and to be used indoors
they have a tip switch so if you tip
them they turn off
they're cool everywhere but on the grate
it also has an oxygen shutoff switch so
if you use up too much oxygen it turns
off the heater
you getting your warm jammies on oh yeah
yeah those things have been nice
you like your bag tom yeah this is tom's
got the big agnes wolverine
bag and nathan's got the big agnes
little red bag
[Applause]
our water froze last night
if you don't know what a scotch egg is
it's a hard-boiled egg
wrapped in mild country sausage rolled
in ponco and deep fried
and they're amazing so we're just gonna
take
and put them right there on the grill
let them warm up by the fire tommy got a
little anxious and bit his cold
but now he decides maybe he wants to
wait
i love scotch eggs
you know they're heating up good when
you get little bubbling bits of oil
coming out
here come on you like that yeah
well we've got some breakfast in our
bellies but we need to break the
campsite down
and get on the road because we've got a
long drive out to west virginia where we
are going to do some serious caving i'm
really jazzed
it's batman undies
bigger all right
guys we're here all right let's do it
let's go caving
i'm meeting up with caving guide lester
zuck with
wild guide services and we're going to
do some serious caving here so we're
pretty excited
this is my helmet i've got a light on
the front
everybody wears a whistle caving that
boy's always had a good noggin
yeah well you always do that you guys
ready to go caving
all right shall we take a walk i'm
really excited to do this with the boys
i've taken a boy scout troop with lester
twice before so
i've been really looking forward to
doing this with my sons
you can look behind you a little bit see
what you're doing all right
tom you're doing good
awesome hang out right over here
whoa do you think you're gonna look at
that and if everything's wet
then everything is slick which means we
move slowly we don't jump
we don't hurry one of you guys want to
go right after ben
get bigger some places yeah so the
entrance is small there you go thank you
okay ben you can stop it
[Music]
look at that cute little bat just
hanging out he's all covered in dude
yeah this is like the rock maze only
cooler isn't it all right so we're gonna
do a little scrambling up here before he
does he's gonna look over his shoulder
to me and he's gonna say
spotter ready ready ben's gonna do that
for you
your dad's gonna do that for you and
we're just gonna protect each other
going up this
my wife and i
[Music]
now right across the top of this there's
a good hold right at my toe
[Music]
he said you guys made a big duplo cabin
all right very important step we call
that orienting the compass which is
north
does that make sense so why did you two
follow me
then it's kind of like throwing down
the
transmission back river yeah yeah look
there's another cute little bat right
there
you having fun yeah
i like this standing up what am i gonna
do we need to go
that way awesome you good with that all
right
[Music]
guys i just realized something we're in
the batcave
yeah there's your full bat right there
cute little guy
yeah i remember
we could just walk right up look at that
big old
yesterday i was climbing somewhere and
the vultures had the nerves
to leave poop on the ledges where i was
trying to oh
we like you being safe
oh look at that so here's the one oh
yeah yeah yeah
i never i never thought of the dinosaurs
living in here
that it might been from the water
washing
so that's a vertebrae you know where
your vertebrae are in your body
oh yeah that's your spine both so that's
one of you there you go
i found a case spider non venomous um
actually uh
tommy why don't you wait until then oh
these rocks are so slick
they are slick you're doing great tom
you got it
look at this cool
daddy why won't you walk again
this is so cool i'm so glad the kids
could come along with this
little shelf while i spot you okay
so there's a lot more cave down there oh
that's cool
so guys are you ready to climb a little
bit more yeah i think i can do it by
myself
yeah i've got your body
oh yeah i got you i'm back here wanting
to go to the zoo
in the aquarium
super easy barely any convenience
we're about to do something called the
squeeze and scramble
so you take your whistles tuck them down
inside your coveralls maybe in your
pocket or something
and then squeeze under these marks right
where bin is sitting
until you come out on this side when you
come out on this side
you're gonna scramble back up so should
we send your dad through the squeeze
first
okay so sit down facing me okay
and now uh listen to me luke you're
gonna follow your feet so just stay on
the floor
tell becca i love her so go for it
oh look at that fat bottom dance you
make the rocket world go round
oh this hole is even smaller oh
my dad tried to do the hard way but but
he didn't know there was an easy way all
right
all right i'm gonna i'm not gonna die
oh okay oh you make that look so
easy it's like getting out of bed for
you guys
okay which is also hard for me the spot
is ready
all right watch your foot holds here
yeah that's the spirit
that's the spirit put a hand over here
you having fun
you're doing great i got you through
look at that all right
[Music]
careful don't run off on your own
wow look at you guys you're all the way
up there go around and follow them up on
top
are you guys having fun yeah you guys
thirsty you want some water
yeah out of all the adventures we've
done how does this ring
is one of your favorites yeah
so do you have um about fishing
a lot of people aren't in
[Music]
i thought like michael as well
[Music]
just get your hips up get your hips up
to the ceiling now step in and that just
turns your hips sideways
look at you perfect
[Music]
[Music]
your six-pack sam my friend oh-ho
oh wow you want to find a little mud
make something down in there
right there there's something some
bottles you can find
it's it's it's my pet maggot so
so if it rains a bunch does it flood
really good in here so
some caves do some don't this cave never
floods
[Music]
itself
[Music]
gotcha or nathan you walked barely
hunched
yeah just you know you can run whatever
all right ben's demonstrating the
fluidity of the motion
left leg up i believe in me
no crying this time i'm a big boy
oh right off your pants that wasn't as
bad as that first pitch
all right let's let's get moving
[Music]
here i just when it turns mine off
this is in here come on out the
satellite
we're done and here scoot to the side
there
okay come on out buddy good job was that
really fun
yeah listen guys we had an absolute ball
if you guys want to do this check out
lester's business wild guides
services here i'll put a link in to
their website down in the video
description
it's a great family-friendly super
affordable adventure
and i would highly recommend it this is
my third time going with them
so thank you very much lester all right
[Music]
just rub where the mud is and it'll all
come off i saw a hockey player do this
once
okay
it was it was a pleasure guys we had an
absolute blast thank you so much yeah
i'm gonna be with you
all right nickels boys assemble i'll
tell you what guys that is one of the
coolest and most affordable adventures
in my area for all three of us that only
cost
125 that is super cheap
so i'm definitely gonna put a link in
the description below so check that out
if you guys
want to do this as well if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching